- [Voiceover] How many people
do you see in this picture?
Let's see, I see one,
two, three, four, five,
six people in this picture.
So, I'm gonna choose six.
This is fun, lemme keep going.
How many wheels do I see in the picture?
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Wanna scroll down and make sure I don't
miss these over here, nine, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16 wheels.
There are 16 wheels.
These four cars have 16 wheels.
So, 16 wheels, let's keep going.
How many people are in the boat?
I see one, two, and three.
There's the guy rowing it,
there's I guess the mother,
and then there's the baby.
There's three people in this boat.
Three people in the boat.
This is too much fun,
how many faces do I see?
One, two, three, four five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10 faces.
Keep going.
How many bottles do I see?
One, two, three, four bottles.
And we're done.